vi chiedo di fare un piccolo sforzo di
memoria
provate andare indietro alla vostra
infanzia e domandatevi comunque tipo di
giocattoli giocavate che tipo di giochi
andavate a fare in realtà se io penso
alla mia infanzia o un'immagine ben
precisa ricordo me stessa insieme alle
altre bambine a giocare a fare le mamme
giocare la famiglia far parlare fra di
loro i giocattoli di peluche
poi invece se penso ai maschi me li
ricordo così quindi fondamentalmente
alle prese con soldatini a fare la
guerra con robot transformers
si tratta evidentemente di
generalizzazione che sono fra l'altro
alla base di molti stereotipi che voglio
evitare assolutamente vi chiedo però di
tenere per un momento questa metafora e
questa immagine perché ci aiuterà ad
affrontare il tema di oggi vi voglio
proporre una prospettiva inedita sul
mondo del lavoro del futuro e vi voglio
raccontare questo il futuro del lavoro e
femmina badate bene non ho detto donna
ho detto femmina e non è mia intenzione
proporvi l'ennesima visione femminista
sul lavoro viceversa penso però che una
visione da maschio alfa del futuro del
lavoro non sia più efficace e che quindi
sia necessario rivederla e interpretare
il futuro del lavoro anche a valle della
tecnologia degli sconvolgimenti di
questo periodo
sulla base di due assurdi da un lato il
modo di lavorare del futuro e femmina e
dall'altro la ricerca di lavoro del
futuro è femmina
quando pensiamo al dibattito sul futuro
del lavoro quello che succede è che
veniamo letteralmente invasi di
statistiche libri letture che ci
prospettano scenari apocalittici
quindi massima disoccupazione robot che
sostituiscono interamente la forza
lavoro fabbriche asettiche in cui l'uomo
è scomparso
io non credo che questo succederà
credo però che bisogna avere i giusti
strumenti e bisogna un po con complessi
ficcare la visione sul futuro del lavoro
e proprio per questo vi rimando alla
metafora iniziale ho come la sensazione
che il dibattito sul futuro del lavoro
in questo momento sia un po relegato
alla questione di robot transformers da
un lato e macchinine che si guidano da
sole dall'altro manca completamente la
risposta interrogativi quali come
lavoreremo nel futuro del lavoro come
saranno le competenze che ci verranno
richieste come gestiremo il tempo e lo
spazio come gestiremo le relazioni
quando ha per esempio quello stesso
robot non sarà più soltanto il nostro
collega magari diventerà il nostro capo
da ultimo questo evidentemente avrà dei
riflessi sul modo di gestire le
relazioni e sulla nostra identità
ecco perché vorrei cominciare a parlarvi
del modo di lavorare del futuro che è
femmina e lo lo è da molti punti di
vista
come dicevamo dal punto di vista delle
competenze dello spazio del tempo delle
relazioni e dell'identità cominciamo
dalle competenze come abbiamo detto si
tratta di una fase di enorme
trasformazione ma non è la prima che
viviamo e non è l'ultima
non è mia intenzione minimizzare gli
impatti occupazionali che questa
rivoluzione tecnologica avrà ma vorrei
spostare l'attenzione
da un altro punto di vista perché eccola
complessificazione e una prospettiva al
femminile che riusciamo ad avere appunto
una visione più complessa più articolata
che più ci dà le chiavi per capire come
andare avanti in questo mondo del lavoro
del futuro
partiamo di nuovo dare competenze tutti
gli studi e tutti gli addetti ai lavori
sono concordi in primo luogo il world
economic forum ma di fatto anche tutto
il mondo accademico per andare avanti
nel lavoro del futuro le competenze che
serviranno di più sono le cosiddette
soft skills l'empatia la capacità di
entrare in relazione la collaborazione
la condivisione la capacità di ascolto
di mettermi nei panni degli altri
tutte caratteristiche che non sono
soltanto attribuibili agli assi ti
imprescindibili dell'azienda del futuro
ma guarda caso che sono anche quelli
attributi che genericamente vengono
attribuiti al modo di lavorare delle
donne di nuovo non ne faccio una
questione di genere
parlo semplicemente che un certo tipo di
modo di lavorare accentratore
egoriferito totalmente rinchiuso in se
stesso non ha più senso da essere
banalmente perché non è più efficace le
competenze del lavoro sono femmina
perché più marcatamente femminile sarà
il modo di lavorare nel futuro quando
mia mamma faceva la cassiera più di 40
anni fa è stata introdotta l'innovazione
tecnologica del codice a barre non per
questo ha cambiato lavoro e non per
questo è stata licenziata semplicemente
un suo piccolo tusk si è reso
replicabile e facilmente automatizzabile
dalla tecnologia ma lei se l'è cavata
alla grande
attraverso altre qualità quali potevano
essere la sua attenzione al cliente la
sua parlantina sicuramente veniamo ora
lo spazio è una dimensione molto
importante almeno sotto due direttrici
il primo è quello della globalizzazione
e dell'internazionalizzazione delle
imprese
diversamente da mia madre adesso siamo
abituati a lavorare in un contesto
multinazionale
e ad entrare in contatto con culture
persone origini diverse
è un grande valore sul quale dobbiamo
fare affidamento e dobbiamo avere i
giusti strumenti infatti non a caso si
parla di diversity en inclusion come
asset fondamentali per l'azienda non
solo come fattore competitivo ma anche
come fattore di sopravvivenza
inutile dirvi che un approccio al
femminile che di per sé è abituato ad
essere escluso dai processi decisionali
e sicuramente più capace di interpretare
le necessità delle minoranze capaci di
accogliere l'altro ma c'è anche un'altra
dimensione dello spazio che è quella che
invece magari viviamo un po tutti più
tutti i giorni che è il fatto che il
posto di lavoro che tradizionalmente era
un posto anche fisico fisicamente un
supermercato
la bottega di un artigiano l'indirizzo
di una banca il vostro ufficio
adesso non è più così il posto di lavoro
lo spazio è radicalmente cambiato grazie
alla tecnologia pensate alle tecnologie
da remoto i sistemi di videoconferenza e
tutto ciò che ci permette di entrare
contatto con gli altri a distanza
in questo senso dovremmo imparare a far
proprio e anche in questo caso diciamo
una lettura al femminile ci aiuta
proprio perché la capacità di lavorare
in maniera agile e ciò che più
prettamente ci consentirà di saper
gestire in maniera flessibile il modo di
lavorare del futuro questa sono io
la settimana scorsa a parigi ai giardini
delle tuileries che preparo al sedex e
forse meno lavoro solo perché lo fattori
mi sono impegnata di meno qui arriviamo
al tema del tempo il tempo di nuovo
attraverso lavoro agile ha cambiato
dimensione ha cambiato corporeità un
tempo si doveva stare in ufficio dalle 9
alle 6 è come dire avrete tutti presenti
e magari più giovani meno dinamiche
ridicole come lascio in ufficio la
giacca così si vede che sono rimasto più
degli altri
oppure altre situazioni in cui lo smart
work in piene pregiudizievolmente
attribuito soltanto alle donne solo
perché si pensa che ci sia una migliore
conciliazione vita professionale e vita
lavorativa è evidente che questo accade
benissimo però il vero tema della
gestione del tempo a mio avviso è che
punta l'attenzione sulla cultura del
lavoro e sulla produttività ovvero non
mi interessa da dove lavori non mi
interessa per quanto tempo lavori ma mi
focalizzo sul tuo risultato e questo è
un cambio di paradigma totale dal punto
di vista anche manageriale e di nuovo
una cultura del ascolto dell'empatia
della capacità di mettermi nei panni
degli altri invece che andare a
verificare in maniera micro manageriale
quello che stai facendo
può farci capire quanto una prospettiva
al femminile possa essere d'aiuto
primo perché entra in campo la fiducia
di nuovo non mi interessa come ottieni
quel risultato ma mi interessa quel
risultato e quindi non so vedere quando
timbra il cartellino
[Musica]
la seconda è quella evidentemente del
multitasking e qui non serve che vi
spieghi perché il lavoro del futuro al
femminile
c'è poi una seconda dimensione temporale
che è quella legata al fatto che per la
prima volta nella storia
abbiamo a che fare con una carriera che
dura 40 anni
questo significa che ci saranno almeno
quattro generazioni al lavoro
millennials che dovranno dialogare con
settantenni istanze diverse aspettative
competenze
quindi la necessità di nuovo di non
avere approccio verticistico e
dirigistico ma di non fare entrare in
conflitto le persone di metterle in
unione metterle a sistema per creare
valore per tutti in seconda battuta e
non è qui una novità è scomparso il
posto fisso
il che significa che siamo entrati per
la prima volta nell'era del progetto
anche qua di nuovo le tecnologie ci
aiutano moltissimo perché non abbiamo
più una visione
care di quello che andremo a fare ma
abbiamo una visione scalare in questo
momento sto facendo questo può darsi che
rientri a scuola di imparare di nuovo
perché life long learning sarà cruciale
per l'occupazione di ciascuno di noi
magari fallirò magari vero licenziata
magari mi guarderò mi godrò la
buonuscita
magari farò tutta una serie di cose che
ai tempi di mia madre erano impensabili
entrata nel supermercato non mi 969 ne è
uscita nel 2006 con la sua bella
targhetta d'oro
e chiaro che questo significa rivedere
anche il concetto di successo lavorativo
pensare di poter avere successo
ininterrottamente per 40 anni e qualcosa
non solo di poco fattibile ma
semplicemente di misano il quarto
elemento sul modo nuovo di lavorare è
quello delle relazioni qui tiro in ballo
in maniera un po semplicistica il tema
della block chain dove il valore non è
del singolo ma diciamo e della messa a
sistema di più elementi in cui ciascuno
porta il suo contributo e vi voglio far
riflettere sulla parola collega collega
sta per collegare e ora di finirla di
ragionare in silos e ora di finirla di
tenersi i progetti per sé e ora
finalmente di mettersi in condivisione e
di nuovo di avere un approccio al
femminile questo mi porta all'ultimo
tema legato al modo di lavorare del
futuro che è quello dell'identità a
valle di quello che abbiamo detto fino
adesso è chiaro che una domanda come
cosa vuoi fare da grande
è quanto meno inopportuna in questo
momento perché non ha senso tanto più se
viene fatta un bambino e questo è mio
figlio che ha chiare aspirazione
ferroviarie e poi vedremo cosa cosa
succederà vi invito ad esso a riflettere
su un secondo tema rispetto al futuro
del lavoro femmina che la ricerca del
lavoro che per me è femmina tanto più
consideriamo le innovazioni tecnologiche
pensiamo al più tradizionale
gli strumenti di ricerca di lavoro il
curriculum vitae il curriculum vitae
altro non è che una sfilza di trofei in
cui io mi parlò addosso senza nessun
come dire contraddittorio e ti racconto
guarda come sono bravo guarda che bel
gli studios fatto guarda cosa ho fatto
qui guarda cosa ho fatto ora se
permettete la parola è quanto di più
cielo turistico si possa immaginare
perché di fatto è di nuovo una sfilza
semplicemente di esibizionismi è
evidente che il curriculum serve però di
nuovo me piace pensare che una
prospettiva di ricerca del lavoro al
femminile sia più efficace
questo per esempio si vede quando invece
di continuamente accentrare l'attenzione
su di me
posso invece pensarmi in un ecosistema
in cui creo valore possa pensarmi
contenuti che dall ricevo e che sono
importanti per la mia crescita il mio
sviluppo professionale che sono
importanti anche per gli altri vi
introduco così il tema del social
recruiting che la cosa cui mi sono più
dedicata negli ultimi anni ovvero
l'utilizzo da parte di chi cerca lavoro
da un lato e delle aziende dall'altro
delle piattaforme social per far
incontrare la domanda e offerta di
lavoro di nuovo mi serve per fare quello
che io chiamo il fact checking del cd
quindi tu mi racconti che sei così bravo
ma io lo voglio scoprire al di là di
quello che mi racconti tu voglio
veramente vedere se il network che dici
di avere viene riflesso per esempio sui
link e di voglio veramente vedere alcuni
tuoi tratti caratteriali e quindi magari
andrò a vedere cosa posti su facebook
senza naturalmente entrare in tematiche
di creazione del giudizio ma pure
valutazioni il sociale crudeli ha
soltanto uno dei tanti modi in cui si è
modificata completamente la ricerca di
lavoro e di nuovo l'attenzione sul
sistema quindi pensate a quante volte vi
verrà chiesto da adesso in poi
probabilmente vi è già accaduto di avere
conversazioni via skype a quante società
di selezione stanno già mettendo in
pratica e mettendo a processo
dei sistemi di intelligenza artificiale
applicate ai video colloqui piuttosto
che allo screening dei curricula e
chiaro che tutto questo porta con sé un
portato anche etico quanto la tecnologia
può far bene può far male al matching
tra domanda e offerta di lavoro
e qui veniamo ai big data big data e
sistemi di riconoscimento facciale
piuttosto che algoritmi che sono alla
base dei nuovi operatori nel mercato del
lavoro
penso a linkedin pensa google for jobs
penso a facebook for jobs a tutti i
grandi della silicon valley che di fatto
stanno ridisegnando i contorni della
ricerca di lavoro facendo attenzione al
fatto che gli stessi algoritmi possono
provocare e replicare degli stereotipi
come ad esempio quando succede che le
offerte di lavoro per posizioni apicali
vengono prospettate ai soli uomini
perché così nel mondo offline e quindi
non ci si pensa viene replicato anche in
quello online
la ricerca di futuro la ricerca di
lavoro nel futuro e femmina proprio
perché a mio avviso va pensata in
un'ottica più di valore e meno di auto
riferimento più di ecosistema più di
condivisione e meno di forza ecco perché
concludo dicendo che il futuro del
lavoro e femmina sono femminili modi di
lavorare la gestione del tempo dello
spazio le competenze come abbiamo visto
l'identità le relazioni e anche il modo
di cercare un impiego
badate bene di nuovo ho detto femmina
non ho detto femminista e non ho detto
assolutamente che soltanto appannaggio
delle donne credo viceversa che tutti
noi abbiamo il diritto e dovere di
cominciare a vivere a comprendere questo
futuro del lavoro in modo tale da
poterlo governare in modo tale da poter
insegnare ai nostri figli
le nuove regole del gioco auguro a tutti
voi un buon futuro del lavoro
[Applauso]